[Music]
what is up everybody it's Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and in this video we're
going to be talking about all you need
to know about the ghost in the shell
franchise whether you're thinking about
seeing the new live-action movie and you
want to know what to expect or whether
you've just seen the movie and you want
to learn more or if you're just an anime
or sci-fi fan who wants to learn about
the ghost in the shell franchise this
video will tell you all you need to know
without getting into the spoilers in
this video we're going to tell you about
the origins of ghost in the shell what
makes this franchise so unique and where
all the different adaptations fit in if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
for all the latest in the world of anime
and manga and without further ado let's
get right into it now what makes ghost
in the shell so special is its unique
blend of action science fiction and more
specifically cyberpunk and philosophy
the franchise has been combining these
genres in unique ways ever since 1989
when the first ghost in the shell seinen
manga was published a seinen manga is
essentially a japanese comic book aimed
at older boys and adult men and the
ghost in the shell manga was created by
Masamune chido although first published
in 1989 the story of the manga takes
place in mid 21st century Japan and it
follows section 9 a fictional counter
cyber terrorist organization led by
major motoko kusanagi who is also the
main character a number of anime
adaptations all the original goals in
the shell manga have been made over the
years started with the 1995 ghost in the
shell animated film the film follows
section nine as they hunt for a
notorious hacker known as the puppet
master but the hunt quickly turns into
much more than a simple criminal case as
a huge government corruption conspiracy
is soon uncovered the film also deals
with important philosophical questions
including the idea of transhumanism and
what it really means to be human in a
world where people use technology to
essentially turn their bodies into
machines at what point that someone who
replaces their body with mechanical
parts stop being human and
become a machine can someone who goes
full cyborg still be considered human is
there an essence of spirit that makes us
human is there a ghost in the shell that
is the fundamental question and it is a
fascinating one the 1995 animated film
was followed in 2002 by an anime series
called ghost in the shell stand alone
complex in this adaptation the members
of section 9 take on terrorism
cybercrime and government corruption in
the Laughing Man and individual 11
investigations although this series does
not follow directly the events of the
original manga it is still a very
interesting anime with 50 episodes and a
feature-length film so if you're looking
for ghost in the shell content to binge
watch this is definitely a great place
to start as always with ghost in the
shell this series deals with important
philosophical issues from the
relationship between modern technology
and social behavior to artificial
intelligence or AI in 2004 a second
ghost in the shell animated film was
produced as a sort of sequel to the 1995
film best known as ghost in the shell to
innocence this film features the same
characters from the previous film and it
is based on some of the events in the
original manga however it is not
directly connected to the previous film
and it can be considered an independent
story in this film section 9
investigates a series of murders
connected to malfunctioning gynoids or
female sex robots our protagonists to
learn that human consciousness is being
artificially and illegally transferred
into the sex box in order to make them
more realistic and section nine suspects
that this fact is connected to the
reason behind the murders as you can
tell this film also deals with major
philosophical questions about what it
means to be human about human nature and
human sexuality this film was selected
as the best science fiction film at the
2004 nihon SF taisho awards in 2013 a
new adaptation under the name ghost in
the shell arise was launched as an
original video animation or
ova this ova was made up of four
episodes and it ran through mid-2014
then in 2015 it received two additional
episodes and most of the cast that
created arise went on to create another
feature length ghost in the shell film
in 2015 and that film was called ghost
in the shell the new movie the event so
arrives take place in 20 27 which is two
years before the events of the original
1995 film in three years before the
events of the standalone complex anime
however a rise has been officially
termed as a reimagining so that means
that the creator's wanted to stay away
from the continuity of the other series
and wanted to create an independent
story in this sense each adaptation of
ghost in the shell can be seen as an
independent story because although they
all share many common elements none of
them are directly connected to each
other finally an American live-action
adaptation called simply ghost in the
shell is coming out on March 31st 2017
and it stars Scarlett Johansson as the
major and leader of section 9 from what
we can tell right now from the trailer
this movie will revolve around the fact
that the major who has a fully
cybernetic body that she has been using
to fight crime was actually lied to
about her past the major was led to
believe that she lost her family in a
terrorist attack and that her injuries
were so grave that she had to be turned
into a cyborg to save her life however
it is implied that her mind was actually
deliberately tampered with in order to
turn her into a deadly weapon for the
government the new movie will likely
follow the major search for the truth
about her past and it will likely deal
with important political and
philosophical issues while also
featuring a lot of action and I will now
talk a bit about the main characters of
the ghost in the shell franchise who
will also appear in the new film first
we have what oko Kusanagi or the major
who will be played by scarlett johansson
in the live-action adaptation she is the
field commander of Public Security
section 9 and she is known for being
strong in mind and body for being very
intelligent
and for being an expert in hacking and
military tactics then we have bottle the
majors second in command at section nine
and an experience special operative with
a long military career despite his rough
exterior in the ghost in the shell
franchise he is actually known for his
kind heart and good sense of humor then
we have uh Tamaki the chief executive
director of section 9 he is a
no-nonsense leader who is willing to put
his career and reputation on the line to
protect the members of section 9 from
government corruption and political
intrigue and we have tova usually
portrayed as the youngest member of
section 9 and the only one with a family
he is known for having the least
cybernetic modifications done to his
body and for being the most natural tobu
saw was recruited into section 9 because
of his exceptional detective skills
because of his strong sense of right and
wrong and because his lack of cyber 9
nation gives him a different perspective
from the other members and finally we
have kuzyk who is one of the antagonist
in the ghost in the shell stand alone
complex individual 11 arc and who will
be appearing in the new film as the
primary villain in the trailers for the
new movie it is hinted that koozie is an
early form of a full-sized Borg created
by the government before the procedure
was perfected with the major he now
appears to be a criminal who wants to
force the major to face the truth about
her past I just want to give a quick
thank you too sir Aras from our discord
server he was the first one to suggest
making a video above the ghost in the
shell franchise because he really wanted
to know more about it himself I also
want to thank him for bugging me over
and over again to get to work on this
project while I was working on other
videos in the end I really appreciate it
I have fun doing this and I probably
wouldn't have made this video without
him and now I will move on to give you
guys some recommendations based on ghost
in the shell including Hollywood movies
and anime series that are in the same
genre and deal with similar themes ghost
in the shell was heavily influenced by
the cyberpunk works of science fiction
authors like william gibson and philip k
dick and of course by japanese manga
classics like al-qaeda if you are
looking for similar
Hollywood films I would recommend Blade
Runner minority report and the matrix
trilogy and in fact The Matrix trilogy
was itself influenced by ghost in the
shell and if you're looking for anime
that deal with similar issues as ghost
in the shell and are in a similar genre
I would recommend Psychopaths serial
experiments lain ergo proxy Kaiba and
cowboy bebop in fact cowboy bebop was
itself heavily influenced by the works
of william gibson and especially by his
short story burning chrome and of course
the works of william gibson influenced
ghost in the shell as well and that is
it for this video thank you so much for
watching if you want to see more content
like this about anime and manga be sure
to subscribe and hit that notification
belt and until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]